[Music]
this I'm going to put a couple of
sensors on your cheek just kind of close
to your to your lips and then I'm going
to put a couple of sensors just by your
eyebrow there's I'm not taking part in
groundbreaking medical research I'm
actually trying to book a holiday well
kind of I'd like you to go to Google so
get some cat photos what are you
thinking about right there that some of
these photos are very funny yeah
something really cute I'm in travel
company Expedia's usability lab in
London it's where the company test
subjects to see how they respond to the
process of booking a holiday the cat
photos are just to help them calibrate
as a research subject expedia shows me a
bunch of pictures of safari vacations in
Africa there's big game Savannah and
also hotels so what are you feeling
there you know this looks really nice
here this image of the hotel pool and I
was a little disappointing to see this
image of the room the room began doesn't
look as comfortable well I look at the
images a camera is recording where on
the screen I'm looking at the same time
the sensors measure my facial reactions
the green line indicates a positive
reaction the red line negative spike
shows you a little bit of
dissatisfaction it's a frown to animals
fighting yeah and then the cheetah who
was eating his prey the data can help
them decide how to better display
information on their sites for example
people react positively the green line
gets bigger when they're looking at
rooms with views when people are
shopping they don't always kind of
immediately understand that they've had
some sort of emotional response to
something so by being able to capture
that through sensitive muscle activity
in the sensors there you can actually
then pick it up very quickly and then
probe on it by making the experience
easier and more pleasurable expedia
hopes to get a leg up on competition
from a growing herd of rivals from
priceline to Airbnb and it seems to be
working expedia's revenue has tripled in
the decades since 2005 from 2.1 billion
to 6.7 billion in 2015 over the same
period it boosted spending on tech from
30 million to 750 million you don't need
to be a scientist to see the correlation
there
[Music]